hello everyone this is Samir from audio
science review I have another tutorial
for you on how to uh understand the
measurements that we have on on ASR
forum and by popular demand this is
about speakers
um it's probably the most important uh
tutorial of of this series nothing
determines the enjoyment and tonality
and experience and Fidelity that you get
out of your audio system more than
speakers do and for those of you listen
to headphones is equivalent although
I'll do a different tutorial for that
um
the other measurement types I could just
jump into them and and explain what the
measurements are but when it comes to
speakers we have to step back and
understand a little bit of the basics of
what we're looking for in in speakers uh
the popular uh understanding is that
everyone's different and everybody has a
different taste in speakers and that's
why there are thousands of thousands of
models of speakers out there
but research that started about 40 50
years ago by Dr Floyd tool when he was
at the uh
Canadian Research Institute
showed that
listeners actually prefer speakers to
have neutral sound if they speak out too
much bass or too much trouble too much
mid-range those were less preferred to
uh speakers that had basically a
balanced response
that research was repeated refined many
many times with more and more advanced
setups and tools and and has been proven
world over there are a ton of companies
that follow this research even if they
don't explicitly acknowledge it and so
it's important to understand that and
buy into that even if you don't buy into
it the measurements can still be useful
for you but I highly suggest that you
buy into that so what does that mean to
have a neutral speaker
has two sounds one is what we call
director on axis sound so I've got a
speaker in here if I pointed at my ear
the first rival of sound lands on my ear
is what is the shortest path which is
direct line to the speaker
uh again we call that on-axis response
and for uh speaker to sound neutral that
on-axis response needs to be flat ruler
flat now when we say flat we don't mean
flat when you you measure it in your
room we mean when it's measured in an
adequoic chamber with no Reflections in
the room at all and there we want to get
a flat line anything that's tilted up
and down or or you know goes up and
comes down all of that adds coloration
how does it add coloration well if you
have 5 DB more in base then it becomes
bass heavy uh you have 5 DB too much at
say three kilohertz four kilohertz it
may sound bright so the gold are simple
you wanted to have flat on access just
like what we aspire to have in our
Electronics you want to measure an
amplifier we want to have a flat
response same with speakers
it's not easily done like it's done in
electronics but it has to be done first
of you know neutral uh experience
but the speaker doesn't just generate
one sound that hits our ear and we don't
listen in antichoic chamber when we
listen in our room the direct sound
comes and arrives at our ear first but
then the sound from the speaker hits all
the surfaces in a room and reflects and
then eventually winds up at our ear
again and there are countless
Reflections right from this speaker you
can hit the sale link you can hit the
floor you can hit the side walls all of
these can combine and arrive at our year
research shows that those Reflections
need to have similar tonality to the
on-axis sound for us to hear a neutral
sound so if the on axis let's say it's
rule or flat but that other cell the
combined energy of all those that we
call off axes is got a dip in it let's
say a two to three kilohertz as many
speakers do then that's deficient in
that and what the brain more or less
perceives is a sum of those two and does
not require perceive that speaker to be
neutral now I want to emphasize that the
on axis response is more important than
the off-axis response in that to a
psycho Acoustics principle called the
Precedence effect the brain puts a lot
more importance on the first arrival the
first sound that hits our ear and tends
to reduce the impact of of access
response but nevertheless if the
off-axis response is not good then the
preference for the speaker goes down as
well
all right so how do we get on access
response and how do we design speakers
in general
um as you see and you probably you know
know is that speakers tend to have
multiple drivers in them sometimes they
may be one driver but it may have
multiple elements in them very few
drivers are just single driver that do
everything why because the requirements
across audible range varies at 20 Hertz
we need to move a lot of air at very
high amplitude for us to even hear base
that low whereas at high frequencies at
20 kilohertz we don't need to move much
here at all and we don't need to be
playing very loud or you know we go deaf
so to solve that problem you know from
beginning of time the speaker designers
have resorted in using multiple drivers
if you use two of them it's a two-way
speakers use three of them three-way and
four-way I don't know if I've seen more
than four-way uh speakers but uh you
know sweet spot seems to be two-way or
three-way speakers
there are such things as two and a
halfway and so forth I'm not going to
get into that right now so
and as you can see as examples of these
two speakers behind me you know you the
bigger that you make the woofer the more
power handling it tends to have and the
lower it can go as you may put in the
right enclosure and so forth you don't
need to become a speaker designer at all
to understand the concepts I'm talking
about but at high level you gotta have
some appreciation that we have multiple
drivers now the way for this to work we
need to split the incoming signal and
feed the right signal to the woofer
which is the larger one and the high
frequencies regard feeder to the Twitter
that's above and if we have a mid-range
we're going to split that yet again
and that's done through a circle called
a crossover and crossover's job is just
basically filters either low pass or
high pass or band pass and it chops off
the audio range more or less it doesn't
do it absolutely there's a slope to it
and feeds the area that needs to go to
every driver now with careful design you
can uh make the uh the two drivers blend
so I can roll off the base as it goes to
the woofer and then I can let the uh
highs gradually come up so that when
they're too combined I can get a flat on
axis response
um from the combination as if I have a
single driver rather than multiple
drivers not necessarily trivial to do
but there are computer tools you can use
in optimization and so forth and it can
be done within the confines of what we
can measure so that gives you a flat on
axis response but it does not give you a
flat off-axis response remember off axis
is what goes sideways and hits the wall
and so forth
why doesn't it do that why doesn't the
sound coming out of a driver be the same
with direct versus what goes off the
sides it sounds like it should be all
the same but that's not the case
we have a problem in audio in that the
bandwidth that we're trying to cover in
audio goes from 20 Hertz to 20 kilohertz
that's a very large ratio for acoustic
product for electronics as a walk in the
park it's not much but for acoustic
product that's a wide range and it
causes a specific problem which we call
directivity with speakers in that
they there's a concept which is a
wavelength you know the if you have a
sine wave sort of goes up and comes down
and if you measure the distance between
those two endpoints there's actually a
distance to it and you can express that
in feet or meters color wavelength and
it's just a simple formula which is
inversely proportional to uh
um the frequency the higher the
frequency the smaller the wavelength and
the lower the frequency the larger the
wavelength so there are online
calculators you don't have to uh you
know do the math although math is pretty
straightforward and here I put in 20
Hertz and you can see that at 20 Hertz
the wavelength is 17 meters uh and
convert that to feet for those of you
who live in U.S and deal with Imperial
um
uh metrics uh is 56 feet so at 20 Hertz
a single sine wave coming out of this
speaker assuming these things could
produce so many errors is quite long
whereas if we go if I go now to 20 000
Hertz which is at 20 kilohertz and look
at what happens now it's only 0.05 feet
so we went from 57 feet to to you know
120th of a feet so now we're talking a
couple of inches and we can convert that
to uh centimeters is only 1.7
centimeters so the wavelength at 20
kilohertz is Tiny and the wavelength at
20 Hertz is massive it's bigger than
most rooms
so well what do I need to know that
there's a concept of physics here that
you cannot get around it's a fundamental
law of physics that has to do with
transducer that says if the wavelength
of a sound that you're trying to produce
whatever length that is and you compare
it to the diameter of the driver that's
trying to produce it if the wavelength
is much larger than the wavelength of
the driver the sound comes out
omnidirectional
for that reason if you look at the door
activity as we call the hard sound
spreads 20 Hertz coming out of a speaker
will go all the way around the speaker
you can go behind the speakers hear the
same bass as you would in front of the
speaker at 20 Hertz 30 Hertz 40 Hertz 50
years because the wavelength again is
you know 50 60 70 feet and uh you know
the driver here is you know it's not
even one foot in this case and even the
larger drivers maybe it's just one foot
whereas the wavelength is 50 foot so
it's much much wider than that now
conversely when the wavelength of the
sound gets smaller than the size of the
driver the driver does what we call
beaming it Narrows his Focus like a
flashlight that's zooming in and the
sound that it radius becomes narrower
narrower narrower it can get extremely
narrow depending on how bad that ratio
is so if I didn't have this Twitter and
I just played everything out of one
woofer initially everything become comes
out omnidirectional out of that driver
but as it gets the wavelength starts to
get close to the dimensions of of this
woofer which happens around you know one
or two kilohertz let's say the sound
starts to narrow down and again it'll
keep narrowing narrow until it becomes
like a laser focused sound that comes
out of that single driver
we have a problem in that we remember
what I said about how we build the
speakers that we give part of the uh
sound to the woofer and this you know
this large woofer and at some point we
hand off the signal to the little
Twitter look at this guy with an eight
inch woofer and a one inch or a one and
quarter inch tweeter
at the time that we start to hand the
sound from the woofer to the Twitter
this woofer would have started to narrow
is is Beam with is starting to be not
all the way to nothing because we're
still let's say a crossover is only one
kilohertz it's not 20 kilohertz
so when we hand that one kilohertz sound
wave Duty from this woofer and we just
hand it to this little guy the Twitter
at that moment the equation inverses
because the wavelength is considerably
large and relative to the size of this
Twitter
whereas in here may have been equal or
smaller than the size of this woofer
so what does that mean on-axis sounds
does not change nothing about this the
direct sound remember whether sound is
beaming or not beaming what comes out in
the middle is the same
but what happens is that the sound that
used to be narrowing in the woofer gets
handed to the Twitter and the Twitter
all suddenly becomes omnidirectional or
relatively so and it starts to send a
lot more energy to the size than the
woofer was
so what that means is that if I measure
the sound from an angle
and I sweep this sound at 20 Hertz
everything's omnidirectional it's all
good but as I get to one Killers with a
crossover is I notice a drop because
this woofer is starting to narrow his
beam so the sound drops but when I hand
the sound to the Tweeter let's say about
three kilohertz is fully taken over all
of a sudden snaps wide again because
this guy is a tiny little driver and
we're talking two or three feet let's
say of the wavelength and that is more
or less
much wider it's not only the directional
but let's say it jumps to 60 70 degrees
which means that if you stand next to
the speaker you now have a hole in a
response as it got narrower and then all
of a sudden became wider when it was
handed to this guy so the frequency
response at an angle for this speaker is
no longer the same as on axis on axis
was flat because we didn't have to worry
about this directivity issue we just had
to worry about just what the on-axis
response is but off axis depending on
where I am what angle and so forth can
be radically different
so how do we fix this well the most
common solution to it is what's called a
waveguide and you can see that shape in
here if you see this carved out shape
what this will do is that it'll take the
wave the beam width of the Twitter that
is gonna that's about to take over and
be very wide and it narrows it down it
focuses energy so that the wave the beam
width the directivity of this guy
matches Direction view of this woofer so
in a way we penalize this guy is
ability to you know play very wide
although we help it by letting it Focus
as energy
forward and by doing that we're matching
the directivity of these two drivers
okay so you're with me if we match the
directivity it means that the energy
that goes to the side at an angle
is the same whether I'm measuring the
woofer versus what I'm measuring the
Tweeter then the off axis response is
going to be similar to what the on-axis
response is now eventually this Twitter
will beam because it will also get to a
point where the wavelengths are
relatively small to that thing and the
highs start to collapse that tends to be
okay we're not as worried about when
that happens at 15 to 20 kilohertz we do
worry about it when it happens at one or
two kilohertz which is very critical
region for uh you know in music and you
know voices and and lower treble and so
forth and so we don't want to see
directivity error in mid frequencies but
a gentle narrowing of overall response
of a speaker is fine
so
just netting all this out is that the
design of the speaker a good speaker
that's neutral requires on access that's
basically rule of flat and off axis that
blends these two and is similar but it
can actually have a tilt to it so that
means we could have less high
frequencies when we are on the side but
we want it to be connected as smoothly
as we can get we don't want to have a
dip in the off Axis or a peaking we want
it to have as smooth as we can get and
all of this actually this is shown in my
measurements and reviews so you don't
have to guess but at high level you can
look at the speaker if this waveguard
wasn't there you could go hmm there
could be problems now there are some
solutions and workarounds that may not
involve having as good of a wave guide
and and their waveguides are better than
others but generally speaking the
current understanding for a good speaker
is that somehow you gotta mitigate the
fact that the beam width of these two
drivers will not match and that you want
to mitigate that now by the way this is
a smaller brother of this guy is woofer
is much smaller and the woofer and
Twitter are much closer in size which
means that this guy is not as hard to
design extra activity because there is
not that much difference between the two
drivers whereas the larger the woofer
gets the bigger you have ratio as far as
well for the Twitter and the bigger
problem you have on your hand so that
but you don't get more bass and other
capabilities but know that you know
sticking a 15 inch woofer in here and a
one inch Tweeter you buy yourself a lot
of grief as far as the off-axis response
of of the speaker's concern
okay so again we'll show I'll show you
all the stuff in measurements but I just
want to make sure at high level you
understand that our goal is that now one
consideration is that you can get a
speaker that has great own access and
poor off access
and it can't sound good he said well you
just got done telling me that the sound
on the side that reflects is going to be
bad because it won't match the on-axis
that's true but depending on where
you're positioned the speaker in your
room What treatments you have what
absorbers you have
you can somewhat mitigate the fact that
the off-axis response is poor you'll be
spending a lot more time mucking with
the speaker in the room to try to get it
to sound good and indeed there are
speakers people about very expensive
high-end speakers they have very poor
directivity and people spend forever
trying to make them sound good in a room
and it can be done you can mitigate it
to some extent but why do that if you
get a speaker that has great on access
and smooth directivity as we call it
then you can place it in almost any room
and the speaker will perform similarly
it doesn't have the ups and downs of oh
gosh this speaker sounded good at a
dealer I took it home sounded terrible
or I said it sounded good and you bother
putting your room to sounded terrible
speaker has good directivity tends to be
very very friendly to your room and the
second thing which I'll also emphasize
when I get into the showing you the
actual measurement is that you can
equalize the response of a speaker that
has good directivity meaning again on
our on and off axes are similar if
they're similar you can actually
equalize it better what is Equalization
it means we boost in and lower different
frequencies
Upstream of the speaker
so if we do that it impacts both direct
responsible speaker and his off access
response so to the extent both of them
are similar but both of them are wrong
let's say there's a dip at two kilohertz
kilos I can boost that on both on and
off axis will obey and work together if
they're not in sync with each other you
can still equalize them but again it
could be more tricky you could equalize
or make things worse because you made
the off-axis a lot worse and or you fix
the off axis and on axis got a lot more
so all else been equal you want to have
a speaker that's well designed you want
your designer to have done both of these
things for you
okay this is this is the most key thing
you want to know about speakers so let's
uh jump into a review which happens to
be this m audio uh speaker is called the
BX
8d3 Fortune is discontinued more or less
but there's some amazing Bargains out
there it's not a perfect speaker but
it's a speaker I'd like and you'll see
in a few seconds why I like it but it's
the one that's sitting over here and
that's the one that we're looking at
um so we have the two-way configuration
I usually show the back panel in here
there's a port in here and this port can
cause problems sometimes
um remember I talked about the
wavelength of sound when the wavelength
of sound starts to match uh become a
ratio of of the height width or the
depth of a speaker you can get what's
called resonances in that it's self
amplifiers self amplifies those
frequencies and not others and those
resonances then
come out of the port when the ports in
the back it tends to be less audible
because it's going to hit the wall and
come at you when the port's in the front
it can be worse
so as a general rule I like the ports in
the back better than I like the ports in
in the front but we'll measure actually
all of these effects okay
so
how do we assess the speakers uh
response then in all these Dimensions
that I talked about if I just showed you
on access response then you wouldn't
know the off access right you wanted to
have a way to encapsulate all of that
now what off access response to I show
you what angles which one's important
which ones are not we'll get to that in
a second
so step one in measuring the speakers
that has to be anechoic was that me so
that means you got a measure speaker in
an anechoic chamber a crappy on a koi
chamber probably costs a few hundred
thousand dollars
a very good one probably costs half a
million dollars to a million dollars and
the one that you want that's flat down
to 20 Hertz probably costs you a few
million dollars and basically doesn't
exist
so but that's been the norm until about
eight or ten years ago was that if you
wanted to get the anechoic response of a
speaker you put it in an antichoic
chamber as these wedges that's basically
swallows their flexions and you just
then put microphones and and you measure
the own access response
also what I call dii DIY techniques for
measuring uh speakers
um those let you measure the high
frequencies fairly accurately using
What's called the Gated measurement and
then you got to do what's called the
ground plane measurements and you gotta
Stitch those two together
um it's if it's not done right they can
show you wrong results so be very
careful interpreting those things uh
many people there are some sites that
only show your response from few hundred
Hertz and up when they do that know that
that's not a good measurement because it
basically has no accuracy above below a
few hundred Hertz so I'll speed an equal
you do want to have uh and basically an
unequate measurement to go down to as
low frequency you want or 20 Hertz in
this case
how do I measure things well take
advantage of advancement signal
processing using a system called clipple
near field scan and clipple is a company
in Germany that's uh started by Dr
Clipper and their focus is on
measurements of of loudspeakers and
transducers about 10 years ago working
with some research students and they
come up with a method called the near
field scanner or near field measurements
so what they do is that you put the
speaker in a room and let me see if I
can quickly bring it up as we are
talking
oops
sorry I didn't think about bringing this
up earlier so a neutral scanner is a
robotic system that you put the speaker
on a stand
let me see if I can uh
yeah hopefully you can see
see in here so you put the speaker on
the stand and this robotic arm with a
single microphone around it will scan
the speaker in 360 degrees and up and
down so he basically tries to get a
cylinder but for purpose of this
discussion just assume it's a globe
around the speaker and it does this at
very close distance
now normally that's not a proper way to
measure a speaker because if I put a
microphone in here depending on how high
or how low I have it I would pick up too
much of the woofer or too much of a
Twitter so you usually want to measure a
speaker what is called the far field
location this on purpose violates that
and actually sticks the microphone very
close uh think about it like one third
one half a meter two to three feet and
measures the uh this basically a
thousand points or more around in 3D
space around this now the advantage of
measuring close is that all the ambient
noise let's there's an air conditioner
running or maybe there's a somebody
walking those get lost in the noise
literally because your microphone is
very close to the speaker and you're
picking up a very very strong signal so
it allows you to measure a speaker in a
non-quiet room and a quick Chambers are
usually built to not only be anechoic
not reflecting but also be extremely
quiet with this system you don't need to
do that
the problem is that those measurements
as I just said they're actually
incorrect because you're measuring
close to the speaker and the two drivers
have an integrated
but through a pretty Advanced
computational phase in that you take
this thousand measurements and and you
convert these single measurements into a
complete computation of the sound field
which is if I had a formula that I could
just plug in any angle any distance it
would spit out exactly what the
frequency response of the speaker is at
any one point it actually computes this
model and when I compute that model I
can put in one meter two meters five
meters 10 meters and I can put any angle
I want and it will spit out the answer
so just think about it as solving an
algebraic equation except that instead
of having you know X Plus y equals 12
and having two formulas it has a
thousand formulas with thousand
coefficients so it's a large thing and
it takes about 20 30 minutes for this
computational phase on a modern computer
to run but once it does that you have
the full sound field so not only did you
enjoy a much better signal noise ratio
when you measure the speed you also
managed to solve a problem of uh of
basically expressing the sound field at
any point you want whereas in an
antichoic chamber if it's not too big
and I put my microphone here then I may
not be in the correct far field and
certainly not where I would normally sit
in a normal listening living room to
listen to music I would be much farther
than two to three feet but building
large antichoic Chambers is expensive so
we don't do that
so make a long story short that's where
this near field scanner part comes from
NFS for short so clipples the name of
the company don't be confused if
somebody just says clippled doesn't mean
this system is in use clipple has a base
measurement system that can generate
tones and measure it but then you buy
this extra NFS system and to complement
that and to have this robotic system
wrong typical time for scanning is about
two and a half to three hours in the
number of points I use sometimes I use
more
um I don't usually use less so about two
and a half to three hours is typical I
let it run and you know I have to set it
up it takes about half hour to set it up
configure it but then you later on for
three hours and spits out this raw
usually close to a gigabyte worth of
data and you take that measurement data
then post processor and a half hour and
out pops out basically the measurements
that I'm gonna explain to you down here
here but there's a second part to this
uh remember I said anechoic room I don't
have an antichoic chamber I don't have a
million dollars to spend on this and nor
did I would I have the room even if I
had the money to spend on it uh there's
another collaborating computational you
could do which is you can measure the
sound field at one point you can also
measure it at the second point and
knowing that distance you can actually
figure out what is that oncoming sound
wave to you versus sound that has gone
and taken a longer path from reflecting
off a wall and coming back and you can
then illuminate and filter out those
Reflections and this is called the field
separation
and it's an optional part of the system
it's just software but it's optional if
you have that software
it's able to then generate truly
anechoic chamber it literally
takes all the Reflections in a room and
he subtracts them out so we subtracted
out the noise that's in the room you
subtracted the reflections now that what
that means is that I can take a speaker
and I can measure it anywhere indeed I
have this system placed in my very large
three-car garage domestic U.S garage
with uh 12 to 14 foot ceilings which
helps to have larger space but some of
the measurements I'll talk about in a
second but
um you just set the speaker in and I can
measure speakers up to about six foot
high above that it can be tough
um but you know that covers just about
every speaking of we're interested in in
measuring you do have to lift the
speaker up to this five foot pedestal
and now have extensions that let me
enlarge that pattern stall so
non-trivial if you have 120 pound of 200
pounds to be getting you John applies on
this uh they have accommodation five and
a crane you can actually lift the
speaker and you know hang it on top of
this but anyway I have this system
unfortunately the system is not cheap uh
it's about a hundred ten thousand
dollars uh for this system and you gotta
buy it from Germany paying euros and
deal with importing and so forth so it's
not something you can snap your fingers
and get it but it is essential because
it will give us anechoic data which is
what all the research is based on okay
then we express it in multiple ways
first thing we do is that we show it in
what is called the on-axis response such
as the black line so first thing I do
when you look at this graph that I post
you look at this line in here and see
how flat it is and we see that in base
frequencies it's pretty flat when it
comes to speakers we don't worry about
little variations like this it's flat
flat and all of a sudden some strange
happens there's a peaking over here then
it goes down and then all of a sudden it
dips again for a while and comes back up
and it dips again and dips again dips
again
and we clearly don't want to see all
these variations but they're there and
I'll address them when I talk about the
equalization and listening test
now what is this peaking in here why is
there peaking
um
foot to understand that you want to look
at these two other graphs the one in
blue dash blue in here is early
Reflections when I said Reflections
matter some reflection is a lot louder
than others the sound that hits the
sidewall and comes to my ear is much
stronger than the sound that goes all
the way behind me hits the back wall
then comes to me it's traveling longer
distance and the sound drops by a factor
with the power of two so it drops off
massively so research has shown that
there are X number of Reflections that
are the strongest in most typical rooms
so we take all of those and weigh them
properly
meaning some are more important than
others and combine them all together you
get what is called these early
Reflections and we plot that in here as
a measure of frequency response of the
off-axis
so instead of looking at you know 15
different of axis response we look at
some of them in expressing these early
Reflections and then if we take the
energy that comes out of the speaker in
full 360 degrees and sum all that you
get this red graph this 10 this used to
be something people went by but it turns
out to not be correct you do not want to
use the sound power of the entire
speakers called The Sound power because
if it did that you're putting equal
value on every sound waves coming out of
the speaker and that's not correct sound
that's you know let's say again goes up
some screwy angle and reflects three
times for a rise of my ear that's not as
important as sound that just instantly
hits the floor let's say and come to my
ear okay but it's there and we show it
in base frequencies tends to be the
thing that we care about because
everything's omnidirectional
so the reason I just explained all this
stuff is that what what I do is that
first I look at on axis if it's flat
we're done we move on to something else
but if it's not flat then look at the uh
these other ones and see if they mimic
what they are on access response is
doing when they all mimic each other
means that this that that anomaly isn't
just directly on access but it also
occurs in all different directions
when that's the case we call this a
resonance I explained earlier what a
resonance was resonance is when you give
x amount of energy to the speaker and it
plays back X Plus y sort of like as in a
tuning fork or a swing if you just get
it the right uh you know uh oscillation
you don't need as much energy to get it
to do that so in a way the speaker
becomes more efficient and spits out
more energy than we want and when that
happens and he said that it also shows
up in off axis we call this a resonance
and you can see here's I've noted that
it's a Resonance of 590 Hertz so that's
exactly what that is we don't know
what's caused it but but we can see that
it's there and good news is that
Equalization is extremely effective on
this thing so I can take an EQ and I can
dial a filter that has this similar kind
of shape I can pull that down as if
nothing's happened and I actually gained
something in that since the speaker is
more efficient there when I lower that
value is actually trying less hard and
it'll actually generate less Distortion
so not only do I get better tonality
when I fix that legalization or I
actually get lower Distortion and so
that's a good thing and we can fix it
um likewise we can see also in here that
when there's a dip in here we also see
there's a dip in these things too so
it's a general characteristics of of
this of the speaker
okay now down here we see these this
blue and and this orange curve so these
two are really just a difference between
these two graphs and the on axis so we
want to see how different the off-axis
response is versus uh the uh um on axis
and then uh the uh sound power so just
two different ones what does that mean
in plain English is that ideally we want
to see a line that has whatever slope
the slope is less critical but we want
it to be as smooth as we can get it and
you can see this is actually pretty
smooth you know there's a little bit of
error remember I said when we're handing
woofer to the Twitter there can be some
error we can see both of these guys sort
of they're going up like this that means
the beam is gradually narrowing that's
fine but then as soon as the Twitter
takes over it sort of snaps a little
wider but then it still continues so bad
speakers will have really sudden jumps
in here here far worse than what you can
see what you're seeing over here
okay but this is less important the
number one thing you look at in here in
an instant is UI should go to the black
line and say what is the black line
doing is it like this line that I've
drawn myself manually this red one and
is it not and we see that it's pretty
good in here we have some anomalies here
and there how bad they are we have to
judge that
okay now I do another test which has
actually nothing to do with that and
it's not anechoic in that to
troubleshoot where the speaking coming
from I mean we've got all these
components we have a port in the back we
have woofers we have all this stuff
there could be a lot of things that
could be causing this problem
um what I use that I take the the near
field scanner and I take this microphone
and I stick it very close to each driver
so I get it right in front of the woofer
then I get right in front of the Tweeter
and I also get it right in front of the
port in the back and I plot those
responses so here we look in here and we
see this is the port the port is
designed to extend low frequencies and
we see that it's doing that it goes
lower than the woofer it goes down here
and then we see some resonances from the
enclosure coming out and what are the
resonances every time you see a peak in
here in badly done speakers these
resonances actually shoot up to become
very close or even higher than than the
response of the woofer itself off when
they do that they screw up the on access
response in here and we will know right
away is because the cabinet is what's
contributing to it so you may be able to
put some stuffing in there and reduce
those and you can curse the designers
for skipping over you know managing that
and they're more Advanced Techniques to
get rid of those Reflections they're
non-trivial sometimes to get rid of on
this thing but in this case just happens
to to actually work out reasonably well
but when I did the same measurement with
just measuring the woofer itself I
noticed that
Wiggles actually in the woofer this is
almost the first time I've seen this
almost always that kind of uh you know
jump like this is from the port but in
this case it's not which means that
somehow this woofer combined with its
cabinet enclosure maybe it's loose maybe
something's going on there where it
literally started to resonate with the
enclosure or something so I called it
woofer resonance but it's really should
say woofer cause resonance
and then I do the same thing by sticking
the microphone directly in front of the
Twitter and we see the Twitter response
and we see that it's uneven on its own
that means that stuff wasn't caused by
the woofer this is woofer dropping Like
a Rock because of his crossover and a
Twitter is is what's generating uh this
problem right here so if we go back up
here now we know the cause of both of
these we see this this basically this is
a 200-day pick doesn't have a flat
response this is an active speaker I
believe uh and there's really no excuse
in active speaker to not correct for
this because they could have put filters
in there if they have the signal
processing power to flatten this and
they didn't this actually sells now
discounted for like 120 hundred fifty
dollars each which was remarkable so I
wouldn't fault it here but for a great
speaker we would have wanted to have a
driver that's smooth and if it's not
then have correction for it in the DSP
inside this
now I talked about the off-axis response
ah we take a bunch of them and combine
them together to generate that early
Reflections but we can actually tease
those apart and look at each one of them
and you can see them all in here plotted
on top of each other and the floor-bound
ceiling bounce the front wall front wall
by the way is the the wall that's uh
um uh from the front of the speaker so
what the speaker sees is his front wall
and uh we have the sidewalls and we have
rear wall what is behind the thing and
then in green is all of them combined
which is what we saw in the other graph
and I just put a trend line in here
these lines I draw just draw it by ears
not by by eye it's not mathematically
accurate
um but anyway uh it sort of shows you a
slope and again there's nothing wrong
with having a slope that overall goes
down but I draw the line to see that
things are sticking up above it and
things are sticking below it we can see
that you know we don't have an ideal
response we have our bump in here and we
have our you know dip over here and we
have the variation in Twitter now one
thing this graph lets you do is decide
where you need to put absorbers and or
other mitigations for example if you
look in here I've got a ceiling
Reflections in dash red and we have a
dip in here already by allowing the
ceiling Reflections to go on they make
this dip worse that if we didn't have
ceiling Reflections this tip would be
less pronounced and it would go up
higher so what does that mean you could
put an absorber on the ceiling and it's
needed from 1000 Hertz and higher that
means doesn't have to be very thick a
couple of inches is probably fine but if
that's not doable make sure the ceiling
is tall so if you have a tall ceiling
like I do in my listening space that
helps
likewise floor bounce we can look at it
and see the floor balance making things
worse yeah it is making Force things
worse it's this blue line but you can
see it's making this peak worse and it's
making this dip worse so putting the
carpet in front is useful unfortunately
this gets used for this specific speaker
I guess you the near field as a
monitoring thing so it's probably going
to bounce off the console in front of
you and that's just life these two-way
speakers vertically never have very good
response but now you know something
about what you can do as far as
treatments on this thing
okay there's a clever scheme that says
look uh all this is fine and dandy but
how is it going to sound in my room that
what I hear in my room is some of the
on-axis and half axis can we blend those
two together and make a prediction or
estimation in this case and we can and
based on some research and verification
of you know comparison of the real room
in that if we combine all that based on
a specific formula we get this kind of
response and you should see basically
that it makes sense in that it we still
have the low you know notch in here we
still have this dip that we talked about
and we see that this overall sound
slopes down why is it sloped down on
axis was more or less flat but off axis
was like this so we combined the two we
average amount it winds up pointing down
flatter this this curve is the more
brightest speaker is the more it dips
the less bright it is that means more of
the highs are attenuated they're a
lightning of the sidewalls
so in general you want to have for
domestic use so domestic means enjoyment
of music you tend to want to have this
sloping down for professional use uh
mixing and and uh
mastering music you may want to have
this flatter and the you know more
professional speakers tend to be flatter
I tend to find both of them just fine
and at any rate you need to apply
Equalization anyway to give it a sound
tonality that you want so I don't care
what the slope is but just know that
generally for your room the sum you want
to be poking down and we can look at
this thing again I draw a trend line
saying look we've got two problem areas
in here but the rest of it actually
looks pretty good look at how good is
matching my line look at how good it's
matching in my life one thing I didn't
talk about is um the base extension the
speaker is this is 20 30 40 Hertz 50
hertz well we barely down at 50 hairspin
this thing goes all the way down to some
30 Hertz despite being a little speaker
and quite cheap well it's not very low
but for in Grants given things as
someone know the the larger one is what
we're looking at but it has extremely
good basic extension and that's one of
the things I found impressive
okay so all of this is standardized in a
standard called the cea or CTA 2034 and
you you must buy a standard uh show the
measurements like this this first one
over here this is me made up measurement
by me but other people do the same thing
but this one's part of the standard this
early Reflections and estimated in room
reflection one key thing about this you
will never ever measure this response in
your room because as soon as you put the
speaker in a room the base frequencies
actually get modulated by your room and
you wind up with very large variations
in here so this is assuming an idealized
room that's been fully equalized or has
tons and tons of treatment in it to have
no modal response as we call it in base
frequencies so don't be confused about
that you could take the speakers and put
in a room and it may sound way too boomy
and it doesn't sound boomy because
that's too much bass that's booming
because your room has certain room modes
that has added 10 15 20 DB at certain
frequencies to the base region so
here we're trying to judge the speaker
we're not trying to judge a rule so this
is a room independent prediction not
room dependent and the more basis
speaker produces the more it excites
those room modes so be careful when you
listen to this speakers in different
rooms the bass dominates uh as far as
the room is concerned room impact and so
you don't get the same sound with bass
higher frequencies
speaker dominates
all right so we that was our tonality
testing we then get into a little bit of
a less chartered territory which is okay
that's our uh you know how good how
balanced the speaker is but what if I
crank it up uh is it going to get
distorted it's going to bottom out it's
going to Rattle is it going to scratch
or is it just going to play as loud as I
want to play so a long time ago I
started this process of measuring the uh
both the frequency response but also
importantly the Distortion
characteristics of the speaker at two
levels and 86 DB and 1960b SPL at one
meter or 3.3 feet okay and
um where do I get these from there's
another site called Sound Stage that was
measuring things I think only at 96 I
don't remember uh or 86 I forget I think
was 86 and so I started with 86 and then
I was like well is there a trend why
don't we go 10 DB higher and I measured
a 1060 me I would say about ninety
percent of the speakers that I measure
have no trouble reaching these even
small speakers even that little guy I
think that one's that maybe stops at an
ID but almost always every speaker I
measure it goes up to 1960 Beyond this
is trivially small tiny uh speaker so in
my book it better play 960b at one meter
you may say well that's quite live it is
not quite loud in base where most of the
energy in your music is 960p is only 20
30 DB above threshold of hearing so you
do want it to be quite loud but yes at
high frequencies it's definitely our
hearing protection when I measure these
okay I use the clipple setup to make
this measurement because it gives the
robotic arm let's reposition the
microphone extremely precisely but I
don't try to generate anechoic response
it's not necessary in my large space
that I use and I always use the same
space uh on this deck so how do you read
this graph this is the frequency
response in-room frequency response this
time in my room my garage but you can
actually see the same signatures we see
the same peeking in here and the same
Valley in here so this proves that the
antiquette measurements are representing
actual performance of the speaker in
room but now you see some uh peaking in
here because there are reflections and
where I measure the speaker
and I've drawn an arbitrary line of of
uh 50 DB in here where did I get that I
just decided to pick that as a reference
everything needs to have a reference so
you know some too high too bad or too
low so here we go ahead and look at this
at 8060b and say what is our response
that's our total Distortion and the
total Distortion is this red line in
here and we see that essentially it only
comes up above my 50 uh uh uh DB
response just in the lowest of of Base
frequencies and then from then on is
well below the line and where our
hearing is most sensitive is this region
and in this region it's extremely low
Distortion I mean we're talking below
you know 20 DB SPL so it's extremely low
Distortion in this region which is quite
good now naturally when I boost the
input by 10 DB or the playback level by
10 DB now the woofer starts to get
pushed a lot harder and starts to
distort when whenever you take a driver
and push it out of his Center position
the farther it goes out of his Center
position the more Distortion generates
fortunately our hearing is not super
sensitive to Distortion here so this is
actually not too bad
um and there are speakers where this
actually will cross the actual response
of the speaker which means that's 100
total harmonic Distortion
um now sometimes this graph is uh
informative sometimes this one it this
is the identical measurement same
measurement just expresses a different
set of numbers here we see the absolute
amount of distortion but if the response
is going down and this is also going
down we care about the ratio of these
two so put on the way we care about how
much Distortion we have relative to our
signal so because our frequency response
is not flat it is useful most of it I'm
going to look at this as a ratio how
much Distortion do we have relative to
our signal and here we see that we have
a peak in Distortion four and a half
percent it sounds like a lot but again
remember these low frequency harmonics
uh fall below threshold of uh hearing so
and you can see how beautiful this is in
higher frequencies but it's just hugging
this this zero percent line in here um
when we go to 9060 be still extremely
acceptable for what is a basically a
budget speaking small enclosure yes it
starts to complain and uh we see that
they're but with this Whenever there are
these narrow spikes that means there are
also resonances in here uh that are
causing problems so
um and this is going off the chart in
here but turns out this is still
subjectively good because there was the
response in here is so clean
were you with me all right we'll revisit
this later on when it comes to listening
tests
um now we go back to our friend I talked
about the beam width and directivity we
can actually plot that which is we
measure at what point uh we have six DB
of drop-offs so just I don't know what
DB is don't worry about just assume that
we pick a constant level of less energy
than on axis what would that line look
like and we pick 6 DB it becomes this
red line and that's what I use and
ideally we want to see a flat line in
here from beginning from at low
frequencies everything's omnidirectional
so life is good but when it Narrows
remember we don't want to have
variations between the when the woofer
is playing which is this region to what
the Twitter is playing which is this
region we want to have these two blend
well and look at how well these two
blend in here they blend quite good in
here we have a little bit of peaking in
here and a little bit of narrowing
that's fine
that one thing I measure also is how
what how many degrees is that flatness
being maintained and uh is basically
plus 60 degrees or minus 60 degrees this
isn't horizontal Dimension by the way so
horizontally up to 60 degrees uh on
either side or 120 degrees total the
tonality is actually quite similar to on
axis this is very good for far field and
even for near field where you're sitting
in a chair and going left and right or
you have a clients in next year and
they've got to hear the same thing but
they're offset than you uh this is very
good 60 degrees tends to be the average
there are speakers there are 50 or even
lower
but by far the most common is 60 degrees
and that's good in my book
instead of showing it as line we can
show basically a heat map and you can
see in here the same kind of thing but
the visualization is prettier and maybe
you can get more insight in here
but you can see the effect in here very
nicely that we have basically skull
control directivity if this thing
extended all the way to the end that way
so we have you know omnidirectional in
here plus or minus 180 degrees and then
we narrow down and then we maintain that
narrowness till we can't and then we
start uh and keep getting narrower and
again as I explained anything about 10
kilohertz is fine vertical is a
different story
um so we're measuring you know right now
we went left and right now we also want
to go up and down we have a problem in
that as we move from here the distance
from this my finger and the two drivers
changes and there comes a point where
there's a difference enough of a
difference between the two in that the
one-way form actually twists 180 degrees
and starts to cancel the other one so
you actually get a dip there you know if
you listen to the speaker and you say oh
it sounds great as you go higher and
higher you get to a point where all of a
sudden you lose use a chunk of your
frequency response then if you go above
that things get better and we can see
that in here in what are called the two
eyes so zero is our own axis response is
this line in the middle
and as soon as we go 20 30 degrees above
it we all sudden hit this eye this eye
means energy is substantially reduced so
we no longer read we're much lower SPL
and that means we have a hole and then
likewise if we go down below the speaker
by the same number of degrees you wind
up losing that so almost in 99 of the
case unless you have a coaxial speaker
doesn't have this issue because both of
them are are in the same position
non-questial drivers two-way systems
will have this problem and what it means
is that you better listen that on Axis
or just slide off axis so like this
speaker right now is four or five inches
below my ear you should position it
where you tilt it back so that you're
losing on axis a lot of times you see
this combatant here stay at two error
axis don't go way above a below because
you just screwed up your uh on access
response because remember this is this
is response at this angle so if I go up
30 degrees I'm hearing a frequency
response with a hole in it at three
kilos not a good thing so almost always
unless said otherwise speakers should be
pointed at your ears with that I forgot
to mention that every review that I do
there's a notation in there that tells
you where the reference axis is so
some companies document this some of
them don't but almost 90 percent of the
time on this set otherwise a measure
relative to the uh Twitter are being
referenced sometimes I go down a little
bit below I do some experimentation but
when we said Twitter access means
reference access usually means the
Twitter but sometimes maybe one or two
inches below if you sit far it doesn't
make any difference if it's very close
that little bit could make a difference
so more or less pointed Twitter at your
face and your gold
okay
so
in vertically we're not maintaining that
now turns out perceptually we're not as
sensitive to these responsors because
indeed that sound wave that's going up
30 degrees has got this hole in it and
it's hitting the ceiling coming down
isn't that a bad thing turns out
perceptually we're not as sensitive to
Vertical Reflections having poor
tonality versus the horizontal response
so it's not as as bad there so this is
Forgiven although in perfect world you
would have both of them look like this
okay
basically we're done by this point I
have two more measurements because
people ask for them but they have almost
no value one is called the CSD or
waterfall and uh basically says give me
the frequency response but give it to me
over time
and the idea is that okay if you look at
the slice in time if something elongates
means that it's hanging the breeze which
means there's a resonance there or some
other stored energy that people call
turns out this thing everything that's
in here is actually originally in here
in the frequency response as well more
or some exceptions but I won't but look
at this thing for example in here we
said this was a resonance right around
590 Hertz so we go down here what do we
find at 590 here see that same frequency
response Peak but look at this that
giant hanging in debris you know in in
space is shown in here too it looks
pretty it looks fancy but we saw that
already but notice over here for example
there's not they need resolution in here
they're about half a dozen parameters
that determine how this graph looks I
can make this graph look as ugly as you
want as pretty as you want and it
requires is an art in knowing what the
parameter should be set to if you're
designing a speaker or doing some
research you can use the waterfall
displays and tune them correctly to the
problem you're looking for as a general
graph it has essentially no value but
you know it shows you some of these
resonances that are there and if you
want to glance at them but usually
whenever there's a peak in the frequency
response there's a corresponding
resonance in here that drags on and I
know them to make people happy this
one's really useless in my opinion but
people keep asking for this step
response uh stereophile uh shows this
thing and basically you know it
simulates it computationally it doesn't
actually measure this directly but
computation gives you the establishment
sets if I go from nothing to a signal
and stay there what would this speaker
produce unusually that edges high
frequency so the Twitter response is the
first thing you see and then the woofer
takes his time and shows this thing and
being a slow device it takes it a while
to for the res you know for the
oscillations of that to stop
um we never have such a signal on the
music nothing goes step from zero to a
Max and stay there and again this is
something that you can use if you're
designing you're looking for some
specific things
you know maybe it has value it I've
never competent on what this means or
what it does if you think you know what
you want it for go ahead is there for
you to look at but in general everything
you've seen in here is frequency domain
we care about frequency domain uh
hearing systems the bank of auditory
filters and there's a filter Bank in
here very few things we do with timing
versus what we do with frequency so
that's what the focus is there
so so far you're looking at the speaker
like this the measurements give you a
picture measurement said yeah on access
response wasn't very flat
wasn't bad but wasn't flat we had good
base extension but we had some
wobbliness in in Twitter in in and
treble response we had one resonance
pick at 590 Hertz and actually
distortions but how does it sound right
um what I do then is that I set up
speaker in this case an Airfield speaker
so I set it up in this near Workstation
kind of it's a normal domestic speaker
then I'll put it in my main system which
is way behind me and then I listen to it
now I don't you know while I have
trained ears I'm not doing this to tell
you whoa well listen to it instantly
tell you how something sound a speaker
sounds and rate it that way that's a
very difficult thing to do you know test
about 100 150 speakers a year no way I
could give you 100 accurate assessment
of every speaker based on oh I just
heard it and there it is part of reason
is that audio is a broken architecture
in that we don't know the tonality of
anything that's produced so if a speaker
sounds bright is it because of the music
or is it because of the tonality now I
do have a set of tracks that uh that I
use for this purpose that I've
calibrated to but still everybody's you
know fallible on this thing so what I do
is that I hook up the speaker go through
exactly the same set of tracks every
time and I form an opinion right away
you know I said oh that sounds a little
brighter it doesn't that doesn't sound
very good or it sounds great
but fine I'll put a pin in that and then
what I do is that I use my Rune player
which is what I use to play Everything
has a built-in parametric Equalization
which means that I can design filters of
different shapes and amplitude and where
they go up or down where they pull
things down I can basically design any
filter I want and I start with the flat
response and then I go back to the on
access response and I say okay we saw
this little peak in here why don't I
grab design a rough filter I don't try
to design it mathematically where it
looks exactly like this but I said all
right we're up four or five DB in here
one I pulled out by you know x amount of
DB down and design a single filter so I
just designed this one filter over here
and you can see that's an inverse of
what was wrong with the speaker I'll
plug it in here and then with just that
one filter in there then I do an A B
test it's better before thereafter
depending on where the filter is I play
content that's sensitive to that if it's
a base problem then I play bass music if
it's you know higher up then I use you
know female vocals and other things and
I'll do an A B test now if needed I do a
blind test close my eye randomly move
this back and forth and then I'll listen
to the say there's B okay which one's
better and then I open my eyes and take
a look sometimes I can't decide but many
times I can and when when I think
something sounds better with that same
frequency response correction that the
measurements showed gives a very high
confidence that there's a you know that
was needed and what the measurements
said in my room in my situation with my
music was proving to be a a good thing
um the rest of these actually was tricky
you might think that you go and fill in
those two dips if again we go up here it
looked like you should uh fill these
dips uh you know to get them to sound
better I did that and I thought it
sounded too bright so I want to inverse
and pull the Peaks down in here rather
than doing that and once I did that and
combined them all I thought the speaker
sounded really really good and this is
not much of a filtering to apply to a
speaker and to salvage basically what is
a amazing value you're getting a power
two-way speaker with an eight-inch
driver it goes down to 39 Hertz and with
just a little bit of filtering it
sounded near reference quality and it
beat that's a majority of two-way
speakers I'll listen to it plays
powerfully and uh very cleanly and so I
was very impressed again pulling this
thing down actually helps with Clarity
and Distortion is that's boiled down so
as far as I'm concerned my listening
test go hand in hand with measurements
they are not just an ad hoc subjective
listener oh I listen to it and it
sounded great and imaged this and that
now my job is take the measurements as a
compass and a GPS and say all right
measurements said there were these
errors in there can we improve if it
rever if we reverse that that problem
now certain things I can't fix if the
speaker is getting distorted playing low
bass is going to get distorted playing
low bass so there's nothing I can do
about it yeah I can filter that and see
if it gets better and sometimes I do
that but in general the tonality issues
I can fix
okay so very long presentation hopefully
you stayed with me but it's important
stuff and it's complicated topic this is
something that on your own could take
you five years to learn hopefully you
got what you needed out of this maybe
I'll do a follow-up video where I'll go
through another speaker and and give you
more practice as far as how to read the
measurements okay thanks for staying
with me see you in a future video
bye-bye